coup la sphère grégory la chambre
d'accusation de dijon ordonne un
supplément d'information avait le choix
entre trois solutions renvoi en cour
d'assises et c'était le procès à l'autre
extrémité si j'ose dire le non lieu et
christine villemin était innocenté ou le
supplément d'information alors m gare
aux deux défenseurs du couple villemin a
l'intention il vient de le dire de
demander la mise en liberté de jean
marie villemin nous retrouvons tout de
suite à l'hygiène à belpech président de
la chambre d'accusation monsieur maurice
simon annulés aujourd'hui 450 pages sur
les 3500 que compte dossier villemin
nuit procès verbaux établis par le juge
lambert ont été purement et simplement
annulée pour vice de forme pas de
non-lieu donc pour christine villemin
mais un réexamen des charges qui pèsent
contre elle la chambre d'accusation a
fait le toilettage du dossier en ce sens
qu'elle a annulé un certain nombre de
pièces et d'autre part qu'elle a retenu
à l'encontre de l'inculpé une dizaine de
chars que nous n'avons jamais sécher de
mettre au grand jour ce lourd désaveu au
travail d'instruction du juge lambert
nommé pourtant pas un terme à
l'inculpation christine villemin elle
est toujours accusé d'avoir tué son
enfant
pour nous cet arrêt
doucement posément s'achemine vers la
solution que nous espérons et que nous
avons toujours espéré et qui nous paraît
être celle de la justice à savoir le non
lieu pour madame christine villemin
c'est parce que le sort de jean marie
villemin il y explique son épouse
aujourd'hui même dans cette journée nous
allons déposer une demande de mise en
liberté dans l'intérêt de jean marie
villemin qui est détenu depuis le 29
mars 1985 ce qui fait un peu plus de
deux années une nouvelle phase de
l'instruction on reprend donc mené par
le président de la chambre d'accusation
de la cour d'appel dit lui même le
président maurice simon a même repoussé
son départ à la retraite de quelques
mois pour pouvoir mener à son terme le
dossier grégory entre